am donnerstagmorgen bietet
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
die heeres sportlerinnen und
heeressportler des olympic team austria
ins verteidigungsministerium
zur verabschiedung zu den olympischen
sommerspielen 2020 in tokio tana betont
dass allein das erreichen einer
teilnahme bei olympischen spielen eine
außergewöhnliche leistung darstellt sie
haben nach dem kurzen termin im
verteidigungsministerium wird die
uniform gegen das offizielle olympia
outfit getauscht denn kurz darauf wartet
auf die athletinnen und athleten die
offizielle verabschiedung beim
bundespräsidenten
beim festakt in der hofburg spricht ioc
präsident karl stoss die erlösenden
worte für das gesamte olympic team
austria
das warten hat nun ein ende die 29
olympischen sommerspiele in tokio finden
mit zwölf monaten verspätung statt
verteidigungsministerin claudia tanna
vize kanzler werner kugler und
bundeskanzler sebastian kurz geben
unserem olympia team mit nur beste
wünsche mit auf den weg ob jetzt in
schwierigen und herausfordernden oder
brisanterweise in interessanten zeiten
leben egal
wir halten es mit präsident kennedy wir
müssen sie nehmen die zeiten wie sie
sind und sie haben sie angenommen sonst
würden sie jetzt nicht darstellen ich
kann ihnen garantieren dass das ganze
land ihnen die daumen drücken wird viele
menschen deren mitfiebern werden die
olympischen spiele wenn schon nicht
läuft dann zumindest über fernseher und
radio mitverfolgen und werden hoffen
dass das ergebnis für sie als
österreichische athletinnen und athleten
ein möglichst erfreuliches ist sie sind
stolz auf ihre ringe das spürt man diese
in dieser wunderschönen kleidung tragen
und ich bin überzeugt davon dass sie uns
alle
die österreicherinnen und österreicher
stolz machen werden auf ihre leistung
bundespräsident alexander van der bellen
unterstreicht die willenskraft der
athletinnen und athleten um dem tante
mia besonders die durchhaltefähigkeit
oder dieses niemals aufgeben
auch bei rückschlägen niemals aufgeben
das ist etwas finde ich was man auf
andere bereiche übertragen kann und wo
sie tatsächlich ein vorbild sein können
für viele sie haben jetzt eine
beträchtliche strecke dieses weges
zurückgelegt sie haben stärke gezeigt
ausdauer disziplin durchhaltevermögen
dem geist und für mich ein
unvorstellbares ausmaß an energie und
zielstrebigkeit
dafür bewundere ich sie und viele andere
menschen sicherlich auch
[Applaus]